[Music]
she wants to go like whatever that
aquarium visit mana right there you go
[ __ ] that's the vibe for tonight
smoke and more smoke please going deep
tonight and [ __ ] we have the trumpets in
the bag when the whip comes down
[ __ ] if you're on the 18 hang up
now when the whip comes down oh [ __ ]
Lisa Joey it's it close the uncle Joey
what's this this weed this is a
perennial and then I got this in the
container witches who wants to bond the
trouble
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what it's
on if you're under 18 hang up now we got
no time to play games get your egg yolks
and let's do this it's Monday night
there's no football there's no
basketball ain't dick it's just you me
the bong some reefer grab my sleeping
pills whatever you got we're going deep
tonight look what we got
BAM with no [ __ ] GMOs it's a
good night
I missed you [ __ ] it's been a
long weekend we're opening up with a
GNote then we'll close on another 1,500
was on beat tonight and you know what's
the dessert chocolate [ __ ] cuz that's
how we run that's it who wants to start
take some weakest start state we take
the 125
you're gonna have Josh Wolfie you so
slip a couple on his [ __ ] me what's up
date Juicy Juice here we are Long Island
I'm coming [ __ ] Friday and
Saturday on top don't say I didn't tell
you don't hit me next week and say Joey
you never told me Governors levy town oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
when the whip comes down it's over Lee
you ready for the first bong hit of the
night this is the one that [ __ ] sunk
the ship this is the one that [ __ ] up
that battleship that's how you do it
that's a correct way to do oh [ __ ] look
how am i messing up your [ __ ] dummies
this is how you do a bong hit are y'all
ready
because if you just hit it like that it
burns slow see see yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah see [ __ ] guy you know he's
gonna tell uncle Joey wait
like I just strolled off the raft in 79
the [ __ ] you mean the land it's a long
time ago we all made do here what do you
always do it's Monday night you gotta
get the party started
it's you and me against the [ __ ]
world you understand me if you didn't go
see the two punk movie what do you do
you went to see Wonder Woman [ __ ]
same difference
[Music]
whoa it's that type of noisy on the
church keeping those stars lino Beto you
to stop here and say you start when they
[ __ ] when the Koreans drop the
missile so you keep [ __ ] around
obviously [ __ ] this [ __ ] here right here
looking we usually get weed in a black
container then it's got no label that's
something completely different
well it's a white container you know it
means surrender this is what the guy
puts up [ __ ] it's over just shoot me
in the head I'm ready you ready this is
training reefer right there he's ready
you don't love this stuff here you
haven't be so happy I look jump with
this sealless a [ __ ] Joey's a genius
look at that look at that look at that
that's the one that killed Sally that's
the one fall away
hold it the mule is always taking power
look you people think we're here [ __ ]
running games and playing ping pong and
[ __ ] it's over [ __ ] I don't give
you got a grinder bastards and smoker ok
tonight's your lucky night get I'm
saying
[Music]
oh [ __ ] the Holy Ghost is coming your
way [ __ ] right through the
speakers on this phone right into your
living room you know why cuz that's how
we lead you ready for another bond you
know we're a super set in tonight so get
ready three scars only what the [ __ ] are
we doing here
oh yeah ladies and gentlemen tonight's
your lucky night if you were bored
suicidal let's say you took one of those
mylanta pills you get suicidal so that's
a good night for you to watch the church
tonight I don't [ __ ] know one of them
makes you want to jump off a bridge one
of those [ __ ] pills they all do now
you want to quit smoking you have to
take a pill that makes you want to pull
the Chris Cornell and [ __ ] like that you
don't need that in your life
stick with the cigarettes [ __ ] I'd
rather you [ __ ] smoke cigarettes and
be around then take chantix the next
thing you know you're hanging from a
[ __ ] noose and [ __ ] off your
building or something what's going on
here Lisa I am well covering suicide so
at the dog show you bad [ __ ]
who said more stars bang bang [ __ ] what
you put that thing I want to know how
does it hang straight up like Prince
said you're a sexy mother what's going
on sanity this is how you live
[ __ ] or you people at home I
don't know what I'm gonna do
take a chance Columbus did I took the
chance I'm not going on [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's look
take a chance [ __ ] you guys are
sitting down on what to do with my life
I want to I T and D and they kicked me
out it ain't over it ain't over - you
say it's [ __ ] all the understand I T
and T is done because everybody failed
out you a bunch of dumb [ __ ] you're
going to young prepare yeah I'm saying
if you're that dumb you got to do
something first go to trade school but
whatever the [ __ ] you want you gotta go
to basics gotta go to University of
Phoenix a teacher basics and [ __ ]
they teach you how the car wash it like
that and stuff from day one understand
me
who said bondage glue you ready why we
have time bye hurry up any longer counts
anymore you still - 14 that's what
happens oh [ __ ] please ready for [ __ ]
Satan's buzz this is the reefer I'm
telling you guys listen to me I know
what you're doing come on right now boy
your boss time to go [ __ ] himself
take that little 1600 you got you're
saving for whatever mine [ __ ]
I know mattress and my wife [ __ ] that
take a JetBlue right here tomorrow and
I'll show you exactly where they get
this week you'll be there til one
o'clock if you take the 5:45 out of
Kennedy
you'll be here by 9:00 a.m. understand
me you'll be at home you'll be at the
Voodoo Lounge by 11:00 look at this poor
bastard over there you don't even know
what's coming down next I hope you guys
all right I hope you had a good weekend
but you know what it's over it's a new
week we got no time to be [ __ ] around
and you know making excuses for yourself
let's clean this [ __ ] right how
strong is that Weebly that's one of the
strongest reefers that's walked through
this [ __ ] door understand it really
is I'm not sure I got a guy that we just
like that Katt Williams joke this this
that [ __ ] last week is nothing this [ __ ]
right here look how much he gave me he
gave me a little bit because the last
guy gave an eighth he drove off a cliff
on Boateng he lost his mind his family
you know he's like the crow you can't go
back I give you a little it snot the
size of the dog in the fight it's the
size of the fight in the dog
Confucius actually said when they
brought him ten dogs this is a look at
it that's nothing in there nice and
green I gave you nice and dry you know
the dog and hearing part of the
three-headed dog this is the way that
that dog I don't know about Harry Potter
of it breathe a little bit focus oh oh
tell you lungs to relax a little bit
inside internally yeah relax lungs
that's a boy now ready okay
we don't either
there you go now you feel good there you
go that's the [ __ ] suck that mule so
oh it was shot man there you go it's
over hold it hold it hold it hold it
look at you [ __ ] like that little
something you said Sam who's the bomb
coach here who's the [ __ ] bong coach
in your [ __ ] world you understand me
Uncle Joe it's my boy look at Oh [ __ ]
got an a tonight you understand me
before he leaves I give him a little
star this t-shirt refrigerator I'm top
of the milk thing I come to this top
what's this
those are the Cub Scouts these are the
[ __ ] these are the Marines I'm saying
is a you [ __ ] night I haven't
seen you excited Father's Day Sarah
Tiana see with new haircut no point for
a new head got a little boy it's amazing
usually when they get a boy from they
forget about the haircuts [ __ ] it all
right cut my hair might not even watch
it anymore
police say yeah how you doing buddy it's
just we for tremendous this is the white
label of debt I told you if you're on
the East Coast you catch them 545 out of
Kennedy you can be right in LA at 9:00
8:40 it's always money and you took to
smoke the bomb that killed Pontius
Pilate
[Music]
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz that's a
place to be [ __ ] youtube.com / c /
Joey Diaz beside that I'll see you
Wednesday night on the church don't
worry about who's on it and I'll see you
Friday and Saturday Long Island levee
town Governors 810 who gives a [ __ ]
you're out [ __ ]
stay black Lee come back